Okay, now let's remember our goal,
replacing our weather icons
through Sunshine with images
downloaded from the internet.
Of course,
before we can use Glide with anything,
we'll need to add
the library to our project.
In fact, we use the same approach as we
did with the support annotations library
adding in the single
dependency needed for Glide.
With just that change, we can now
use Glide throughout our project.
So what does it take to replace our code
for loading icons with a call to Glide?
Let's take a look at the detail
fragment, as an example.
In this case,
we're using a utility method
to retrieve the correct resource id,
based on the weather condition id.
So, what does Glide look?
Pretty similar, in fact,
we'll create a Glide instance,
passing in either a context,
activity, or, in this case,
a fragment, and use load,
passing in the URL of the image
to load conveniently provided
by a different utility method.
Then, we'll request that Glide load
that image into our image view.
Just like that we've written everything
we need to download, cache, format,
and display the loaded image in our app.
Not bad for three lines of code.
Of course we probably also want
to ensure that the app works
even if there isn't a network connection
and we haven't cached anything.
For that we can use the error method to
fall back to our local image resources.
Glide offers a number of
convenience methods like this
to allow placeholder images,
cross fading, center cropping, and
more but this will work great for
what we need for sunshine.
There is one caveat.
When we use an image view
with wrap content and
we set the image view
via set image resource,
you're actually taking advantage of some
built in functionality where the image
view would automatically resize itself
based on the image's dimensions.
However, when loading
images from the network,
we'll need to set a specific flag,
adjust view bounds.
This ensures that after glide loads
the image from the downloaded bitmap.
Image view will adjust
its view bounds to match.
So what changes when we
don't have an image view?
Brought up at the beginning to gather
images into our notifications,
this is a slightly different problem.
We somehow need to get a bitmap
to add as our large icon.
What does this mean for Glide?
Most of this should seem familiar,
create a glide instance,
load from a URL, fall back to our
local artResource if an error occurs.
But there's a few new methods in here.
AsBitmap is what tells Glide to
load the image as a simple bitmap.
Turns out that Glide can also load
animated gifs, which, unfortunately,
don't work for
our notification large icon.
Then instead of using
into with an image view,
we pass in a fixed width and height.
This is what tells Glide to
load it as a fixed size bitmap,
rather than dynamically resizing it
based on the size of the image view.
But how do we know what size
the large icon needs to be?
On gingerbread and lower devices
it was a fixed size, 48 DP.
On newer devices we can use
the provided dimensions,
notification large icon with and
notification large icon height to ensure
that we always get the perfect size.
Then we use get to request the glide,
retrieve the bitmap synchronously or
wait here until the images are treat
as we build our notification
in our sync adapter,
which runs on a background thread, it's
okay to block until we get a result.
Definitely not something we
want to do on the UI thread.
Make sure to catch
the interrupted exception and
the execution exception from get.
While we don't expect
these things to happen,
it's much better to fall back on
our local art resources than crash.
If everything goes according to plan,
we'll have a perfectly sized bitmap
we can pass on to our notification.